there's so many ways to answer the
question why explore psychedelic
what does everyone know I'm called LSD
but these drugs get deep into the psyche
I think the value of psychedelics lies
in their potential to be effective
treatments for patients who are not
responding to conventional treatment we
should recognize human beings have an
urge to change their consciousness I
often think about it in terms of
Dorothy's trip to eyes
the laws about many substances were
passed with total disregard for the
evidence so now we're at the stage
there's more psychedelic research at any
time in the last 15 years
[Music]
the psychedelic science conference takes
place in Oakland California every few
years and features researchers studying
the potential medical applications of
psychedelics like LSD psilocybin
mushrooms and MDMA the field of
psychedelic science has exploded over
the past decade at this year's
conference researchers talked about the
past present and future of this
controversial and increasingly promising
area of medical research the field of
psychedelic science when I was first
starting Maps was completely dead there
is clear evidence of serious
psychological and emotional disturbances
resulting from even a single use of LSD
we're starting with a kind of hysterical
background with 40 years of
misinformation and kind of government
running around screaming for the last 50
years has been very to move basically
people don't want to touch it don't want
to talk about it all most people survive
even a really bad trip and with an
injection of one of the most powerful
tranquilizer is known they can get
safely back to reality 2530 years ago
when I first started talking and write
about the importance of this work senior
colleagues would caution me that this
could be a potential career killer we
lost two three decades of time we're
active investigations that have occurred
the preeminent home of the hippies San
Francisco there was such a massive
reaction to the psychedelic culture of
the 60s that not only did everything get
criminalized and Nixon ramped up the
drug war but they also shut down all the
research so when I looked at the history
of the 60s and tried to see what kind of
mistakes were made mistakes that we
don't want to repeat as we really try 50
years later to reintegrate psychedelics
into society the key message for me is
that we have to become the reliable
experts both on the risks and the
benefits the second Monday we give them
a small
of LSD in the five-man Ward together but
döblin says that reforms to the FDA in
the 90s finally opened up research on
psychedelics again allowing scientists
to pick up where their predecessors left
off decades ago this new division the
poly drug evaluation staff got the
responsibility to review psychedelic
research and they wanted to put the
science over the politics looking back
at the conference's that have taken
place the kind of conference those
amongst the people attending was I
wonder if we can do this what if we can
get some studies approved I wonder if
the regulatory agencies will ever let us
explore the potential benefits of
psychedelics of medicines the research
challenges for any psychedelic are that
it costs a lot more to do research than
the research itself because there's all
these levels of bureaucratic concern the
tide started to turn around 2013
although federal government still
criminalizes psychedelic use the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies or maps which helped
organize the conference has managed to
fund breakthrough research one study
found that mdma-assisted therapy could
help veterans suffering from PTSD when
other treatments had failed another
paper out of Johns Hopkins found that
therapy in conjunction with psilocybin
mushrooms can help ease the mental
suffering of terminal cancer patients we
found statistically significant
lessening and anxiety over the many
months following the active treatment
session there's more psychedelic
research at any time in the last 50
years we're at this transition from
phase 2 to phase 3 and phase 3 are the
studies that are going to be used to
make these drugs into legal prescription
medicines
[Music]
and the success of the early MDMA and
psilocybin studies has led more and more
researchers to jump into this field of
study all of the work that went before
helps move the way for us we're just
going to do one with LSD and alcohol
addiction I'm just about to do start one
with micro dosing LSD to see how it
helps with mood depression and also how
it helps with cognitive functioning
we're exploring the research question
can mdma-assisted therapy help reduce
symptoms of social anxiety our group at
Harbor UCLA and other groups at Hopkins
NYU elsewhere also throughout Europe are
beginning to demonstrate that some of
the most difficult patients out there do
seem to be manifesting a positive
response sometimes to only one treatment
session within the context of an ongoing
psychotherapy the things that we're
talking about with psychedelics is a
whole different paradigm it's a
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy where
you only get the psychedelics a few
times one thing that helped me
understand the nature of what we're
doing is when I kind of stepped away
from the notion that they're really drug
studies we have the language and the
tools and the systems for studying drugs
but what we're actually studying the
therapeutic benefit in theory comes from
experiencing an altered state of
consciousness for a limited period of
time like everything is falling apart
by either an electronic microscope and I
can see how the atoms and everything I
often think about it in terms of
Dorothy's trip to Oz there she was in
black-and-white Kansas go along things
seemed fine but when she was suddenly
transformed by writing that tornado to
Oz and landed in the world of the yellow
brick road in Emerald City and a horse
of a different color and all sorts of
interesting characters she must have
been changed as a result of that
experience but at the end of the day
[Music]
there's no place like home and she comes
back to where she started in all the
same people are there she's back in her
home in her own bed that you can bet
that she's been changed from that
experience of having been to Oz it
reboots
the brain can reset like in depression
on the diction underlying those
condition there's a rigid set of thought
and behavior and it seems that a
psychedelic can shake that rigidity and
reset it and as the research continues
to march forward advocates who were
heartened by the recent success of
marijuana legalization are already
plotting a path forward for the
legalization of psychedelics the fact is
the laws about many substances were
passed with total disregard for the
evidence they were passed for political
reasons and they can be undone for
political reasons the 20-year plan is
that between now and 2021 we will be
initiating phase three studies and other
groups will be initiating them for
psilocybin so by 2021 I think we will
have legal access to MDMA for
post-traumatic stress disorder
psilocybin for depression you could
remove them from the most restricted
schedule one is their end of the moment
to allure schedule and then open clinics
which provides academic assisted therapy
one by
tennis conditions and we will use these
clinics as a route of expansion because
I think drugs should be legal right now
but since that's not going to happen we
need to make sure that we can bring
these into society so that we don't have
a backlash it's also a fundamental human
right to explore one's own consciousness
we have the freedom of the press the
freedom of assembly the freedom of
religion and all of those in a way are
based on the freedom of thought
[Music]
you